hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational it's around three
and we are starting in the match with
Fabiano Caruana vs Magnus Carlsen the
first game that finished and it's
already quite a game featuring quite an
opening so after after defeating his
future rival Alireza future Carlson
takes on his former rival who him who he
fought in the 2020s sorry 2018 World
Championship match Fabiano Kawana
so without further ado let's check it
out as it's already interesting from one
here Fabi opens with E for and Magnus
replies with none other than aliens
defence with 90 to f6 and this is this
is very enjoyable that Magnus is not
just playing to win but he's also he's
also experimenting with new stuff seeing
the idea his defense on this level well
it's just very exciting not as exciting
as Naples French but but still so Knight
of 6 we have E 5 Knight to d5 we have d
4 D 6 and c4 challenging that night
Knights to b6 and here well there are a
lot of very interesting continuations
for white you could capture equal to a
knight of 3 Fabi goes for f4 the four
pawns attack against aliens defense and
g6 by Magnus preparing to fianchetto the
dark square bishop we have Knight to c3
and now Bishop to g7 so the usual stuff
black allows the whites to grab this
massive central control here and black
will try to undermine the pawns as maybe
they are just a bit overextended so
Bishop to e3 and now Bishop to e6 this
is the the modern way to play this line
going after the C c4 pawn but not really
here Fabi just allows it and Knight to
f3 and capturing the pond isn't isn't at
all good for black for example if you
capture white just traits capture status
and now you have this Queen to a4 check
which would pick up the bishop
however you have b5 and then we have
Knight characters captors and captures
would check where black has several
options to choose from whether he wants
to play c6 9b d7 but all in all I didn't
really gain anything
especially not a full pond so instead
Magnus just castles but he did spend
some time here so it's hard to say if he
if he checked this line at home I think
he even spent a few minutes on this move
and be three by Fabi now we have D
captures on e5 and now there is one in a
game in the database 4f captures and if
I was played but here Magnus just goes
sorry father goes D captures on e5 and
offers up a queen trade while still
blocking the dark square bishop of
course with knife to c6 by Magnus he
doesn't mind trading he's just gonna
recapture with the rook to get the rook
on the open D file and Knights the e4 an
excellent square for Fabi
we have f6 by Magnus now breaking up
this strong central structure and now
Knight the c5 going after the pawn but
also the b7 pawn the bishop and the b7
pawn and while you could go back with
Bishop to c8 Magnus prefers Queen to c8
and just keeping around the bishop so if
the bishop is captured the Queen is
immediately developed and the rooks are
nicely connected here Fabi continues
with each captures on f6 which is maybe
a bit bit brave maybe just finishing
development first is the way to go but
okay fabulous sights the captured and
the Magnus captures with the bishop and
the justification behind behind leaving
this isolated pawn on e7 is that keep
the white king in the center a little
bit longer because the rook here on a1
is under attack and if you try to defend
it you don't want to go Ruby 1 as then
black has a Bishop f5 so let's say rook
c1 but then you go after the rook and
now after you attack it not a bishop to
see Bishop d3 going for Bishop to b4
check and it's gonna be it's gonna be
problematic for White's to finish
development for example you could go
Bishop b3 but then Bishop b4 check and
now you cannot block with the bishop
because you lose the night and if you
block with the night
now then Bishop g4 attacks the Queen and
after let's say Bishop defense you get
captures captures and Queen at 5 now
with a double attack under broken on the
night well with an attack on the rook
and the double attack on the night so
here well black black is just much
better me if not winning so after this
Bishop captures an f6 fabulous sights
for Bishop to e2 he says okay you opened
up your King side and this
dark square Bishop is the one of its key
defenders so I don't mind giving up my
rook for that Bishop and Magnus of
course agrees he says yeah I don't plan
on grabbing that anytime soon so rook to
b8 attacks the Queen and Queen to see
one now and now Bishop to a5 not
allowing any rook to be one action he
still wants the option of capturing the
rook if he feels that the opportunity is
right
so Bobbi castles and now Knight to d7
challenging the knight and c5 we have
Knight back to d3 now blocking the
diagonal so maybe rook to d1 will be
next and here Magnus in fact decides to
capture the roof so Bishop captures we
have a queen capture son a1 not a lot of
dark square weaknesses along the along
this diagonal but Magnus is not worried
Knight to f6 and now this isolated pawn
here will even serve as a nice defender
of the knight on f6 looks a bit weird
but if it works why not
so Knight d2 e 5 just getting the right
to it to this beautiful central outpost
we have Knight captures other night
characters and now Queen to east six
just developing the Queen and now
hopefully you wanna double your rooks
under default it's gonna be a problem as
a far BC bishop pair is completely
covering all of the squares that the
rook might use to double up so Bishop
the d4 first getting the bishop to this
diagonal and now Knight to d7 just again
Magnus wants to trade some pieces also
if the knight moves the bishop on e2
hangs so first h3 and now Knight
captures on e5 we have Bishop
characteris on e5 and the c6 now as the
pond was under attack and here Queen to
c3 I just a much more active Square for
the Queen here my father you might have
some ideas of shifting the Queen over
the Kings side you never know what what
can happen and here h5 by Carlsen he
doesn't want to start doubling up here
for example and allow g4 could be a very
annoying so instead h5 not allowing g4
and now rook the e1 so now the bishop
can move as the bishop on e2 was hanging
we have King to f7 and now Queen to g3
so now Fabi already has some ideas of
infiltrating on the Queen side here
or even like this so rook the d2 as a
hobby abandoned his coverage of the D 2
square so Magnus uses this opportunity
to double up on the D file and Bishop to
f3 now getting the bishop out of harm's
way now also preparing some nasty
discoveries with the rook but Magnus
says there are no nasty discoveries here
he just spins the bishop rook to d3 and
in fact if you look at it pretty much
every every piece and every point of
Magnus's is on a light square other than
these two guys here but not not not
really pointing in attacking those or
even if even if you could but you can't
so instead just Queen to g5 unpinning
again preparing to make his way with the
Queen into the into blacks camp but
Magnus says there's nothing there just
rook a to D 8 and here Fabi before
continued his attack he wants to shift
is king over to g3 where it will be much
safer presumably so King F to Magnus
continues with a check Rudy to check and
the now comes King to g3 and here you
can't go for something like rook
captures here because then Bishop the c3
will be in fact a pretty good discovery
since you're east 7 point is also
attacked you would have to guard it with
the Queen and then let's say Bishop
captures on h5 will be very strong for
white if you capture you lose the bishop
on f5 and so on so instead Magnus just
keeps it cool he brings it one more rook
into the attack probably not worried he
does have his light square bishop here
and here Fabi just goes Queen to h6 but
there is something more in the position
that the Fabi missed so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
idea
Magnus played while I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting that that well
this bishop that's defending White's
position isn't all that impressive after
all and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show
it's Bishop captures on h3 and now
Magnus esta well Fabi has to figure out
how to go about this first of all let's
go let's see if you can if this is
something or not for example check
you're gonna move the King check you're
gonna move the King and then there are
no more checks or
basically ways of continuing the attack
so not much going on there what you
could try on the other hand is actually
to grab the bishop but if if pawn
captures you just run into a forced mate
rook captures King captures Queen
captures on h3 King to e4 only move and
now Queen d3 is made as the Bishop and
pawn prevented from escape revenge the
King from escaping to the dark squares
so after Bishop captures on h3 Fabi just
unpinned King to h4 but now Magnus just
says okay queen g4 is mate
if this bishop wasn't covering g4 so
let's just get it away from the g4
Square and plays rook captures and g2
and it was in this position unmoved 32
that Fabiano Caruana resigned the game
and the game one goes to Magnus Carlsen
and water when it is with the black
pieces
Ian's defense in only 32 moves just just
brilliant stuff so here obviously
resigned because if captures then its
mate and if you don't capture well
there's really nothing for you to do now
like nothing you know whatever you do
you could again try some some checks
here but we already said that once the
King hides in these seven there's
there's nothing to be done there and you
can just wait to be to be destroyed now
this is a threat characters followed by
mate and there there are no there are no
threats here so after Luke G 2 he
resigned and like I said game one goes
to Magnus so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
William McKay Gavin crook Joe labrum
Bolin market and butter cuts here for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos you're thinking for watching and
I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Magnus Invitational
until it finishes thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day